You've seen the videos, right?
An encounter with the police
that seems to start out OK, but
then just spirals into chaos.
It's a scene we see online all
the time, and it can be really
confusing.
Today, we're going to
deconstruct why those viral
arrests so often look the way
they do, by digging into two
completely different and
conflicting sets of rules for
how the world is supposed to
work.
And it's so often comes down to
this exact face, that look of
just pure jaw on the floor shock
right when the handcuffs click.
It's more than just surprise.
It's a look of total
bewilderment, like the
fundamental rules of reality
just got rewritten on them.
So what is going on there?
Well, the answer starts with a
really powerful and usually
unspoken belief.
It's a concept that the source
for this explainer calls the
consent illusion, and it's
basically the default setting
for many of us.
It's the belief that, you know,
social interactions are a two
way St. that there are mutual
agreements where you can always
negotiate.
And we're saying no is a valid
move that has to be respected by
the other person.
And look, this worldview doesn't
come from nowhere.
It's actually a product of the
environments a lot of us live
and work in.
Think about universities,
offices or quiet suburbs.
In those places, the rules
really are based on etiquette
and voluntary cooperation.
No is a perfectly reasonable
response that usually ends the
conversation.
The trouble starts when that
world with its rules smashes
right into another one.
And this is where it all goes
down.
This is the moment of impact
when the person operating under
the consent illusion meets a
system with a completely
different and non negotiable set
of rules.
It's a collision of expectations
and it's really the root of all
that confusion we see playing
out in those videos.
So let's just lay these two
competing realities out side by
side.
On one hand, you've got the
consent allusion.
We can call those your rules.
The interaction is a discussion.
No is a valid option.
Negotiation is always on the
table.
But then you have their rules,
the officer's rules, which are
built on something called the
escalation ladder.
For them, compliance is an
optional.
It's required.
The interaction isn't a
discussion, it's a procedure.
And no, isn't a negotiation
tactic.
It's a trigger.
A trigger to start climbing that
ladder.
So let's define that term, the
escalation ladder.
You can think of it as an
internal flow chart that every
officer has in their head.
It's a procedure for gaining
compliance.
It's not something they hand you
in a pamphlet, but it dictates
their response, and pretty much
every action you take determines
whether they stay put or move up
to the next rung.
OK, so how does this climb
actually work?
It isn't always some big
dramatic moment.
It's usually a series of small
but really significant steps up
a ladder of increasing force.
And get this, you can be moved
right up that ladder without
ever getting physical.
Things we might see as just
arguing, like loud and
aggressive body language or
openly defying a command.
Those are big red flags in their
world.
Even things like being obviously
intoxicated or according to the
source, wearing certain clothes
or having certain tattoos can be
seen as indicators of
noncompliance.
Each one is a little tick on an
internal meter, moving them
closer to that next rung.
And here are the rungs
themselves.
Step one is simple verbal
commands.
Sir, I need you to step out of
the car.
If that fails, it moves to Step
2, physical control, hands on
contact to guide or move you.
Next up is Step 3 restraint,
which usually means handcuffs.
If there's still resistance, it
climbs to Step 4 tools like a
Taser or pepper spray.
And the final rung, of course,
is lethal force.
Each step up is considered a
direct and necessary response to
the failure of the one before.
So you might be wondering, why
is it so hard to go back down
the ladder?
This quote from the source
material really gets to the
heart of it.
Once an officer starts climbing,
backing down becomes
institutionally really, really
difficult.
There's more paperwork, their
reputation is on the line, and
from their perspective, the
threat to their safety has
increased.
There's this powerful momentum
that keeps things moving in One
Direction only now the author of
our source takes this whole
framework and zooms out,
proposing a much broader and
pretty provocative theory about
how these systems play out
across society.
And I want to be really clear
here.
What follows is the author's
specific argument that he's
putting forward.
His argument is that for certain
populations, ones he describes
as being managed by the state,
the goal is actually not reform
or rehabilitation, It's
containment.
In this view, the strategy is to
effectively quarantine social
problems, to just contain the
chaos, not to cure it, and to
only step in with force when
that chaos threatens to spill
over.
And the author's theory
continues from there, claiming
this leads to a kind of cultural
double standard.
He identifies a class of
observers who he calls
paternalist humanists who in his
view interpret the same
behaviors in very different ways
depending on who's doing them.
For example, he suggests that
defiance of a lawful order from
someone in what he calls a
managed population might be
explained away as an authentic
expression, or that an anti
authority stance is seen as a
tragic but inevitable part of
their condition.
Again, this is his analysis of
the cultural dynamics he sees at
play.
All right, so let's bring all
this back to the here and now.
Why does understanding these two
clashing systems, the consent
illusion and the escalation
ladder, matter so much today in
our world of smartphones and
constant social media?
It matters because today, every
single one of these encounters
is basically a performance for
two completely different
audiences online.
The footage of somebody clearly
operating under the consent
illusion goes viral, and for one
group, it confirms their entire
narrative about injustice and
abuse of power.
But for another audience, that
exact same video confirms their
narrative about the need for
decisive action and escalation.
Both sides watch the same clip
and see absolute proof that
they're right.
So when you strip away all the
commentary, all the different
realities, what are you left
with?
You're left with a very simple
number in any of these
encounters.
This is the number of people who
actually have the escalation
ladder and all the institutional
power that comes with it on
their side.
Which brings us to the final
crucial question.
When two sides are playing what
they think are two totally
different games with two totally
different sets of rules, who
ultimately has the power to just
flip the whole table over?
Understanding the answer to that
is the key to understanding that
look of pure shock, the exact
moment a person realizes what
game they were really playing
all along.